[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [__]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [__] him
[Music]
happy friday
i got a question
[Music]
a very
very serious question
how treasonous are seditious sexed
messages
oh
is seditious sexting a crime i believe
it it could be i believe it is
uh do you guys think seditious sexting
is a crime oh my god
uh we thought we thought the uh the big
news this week
was gonna be that there's sufficient
evidence inside the manhattan da's
office that the current manhattan d.a
who was just elected alvin bragg will
not act upon
that donald trump has committed several
felonies
that which he could be held fully
accountable
by definition from the assistant the the
the special assistant district attorney
former pomeranz
that was supposed to be the big [__]
news
it's gonna shake the earth
and then yesterday bob woodward and bob
costa the bob's as it were bob and bob
bobo and bobby
break a story
and the story goes like this
jenny thomas
the wife
of the supreme court justice clarence
thomas
you know that [__] [__] box
the one the one vote to make sure that
the january 6 records of donald trump
didn't get in the hands of the select
committee
hmm seems suspicious now that's
that's suspicious
the one vote
clarence thomas his wife jenny thomas is
a [__] q another
i'm not [__] you it's not just it's
not just for me it's not just that she
was trying to help donald trump
commit
the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
from from the bedroom
of a supreme court justice
you're telling me that clarence thomas
didn't know
that that jenny thomas was seditiously
sexting
mark meadows that's what i'm gonna call
it seditious sexting i don't give a [__]
that's what we're calling it here
think about this
you telling me that clarence thomas had
no [__] idea not one god damn clue
that his wife jenny thomas was in
communications with the chief of staff
of the office of the president of the
united states the white house
and texting him crazy ass chewing on
[__]
crazy ass queueing on [__]
this isn't like she was like oh
mark please make sure the president
knows
that we're all here to support him even
though
he lost and we think he won nope
nope
this is straight up
[__] whack-a-doo my pillow nazi mike
mike lindell
traitor mike flynn the kraken sydney
powell q and on [__]
the cult
it's a [__]
cult
who said it 100 times here on this show
i've been saying it for over a year it's
a [__] cult
and jenny thomas the wife of clarence
thomas the supreme court justice
the thing that
really catches me here is in one of
these [__] sextas sex messages
these seditious sex messages that she
sends to mark meadows
she says the elites are trying to keep
donald trump from being the president of
the united states or some [__] like that
she
she thinks that there's other people
more elite quote unquote
i guess in the political sphere i have
no idea what the [__] she's talking
about
then the wife and the supreme court
justice and the white house chief of
staff
and supposedly the the
blue collar billionaire the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants
the president united what the [__] are
you talking about you're all [__] ivy
league educated
you're all [__] rich you're living in
and watching these people are absolutely
[__] delusional the cheese has slid
off the cracker
and we want these people to be in power
of anything [__] anything in this
country these people shouldn't be
running a [__] cash register for for
crying at the bigly wiggly for crying
out [__] loud
these people want to not only be in our
government they want to control it
i would say if clarence thomas and
supposedly he has left the hospital
which seems a real [__] convenient
for the timing of all this
too bad infection didn't win that
[__]
resign or impeach i think that we need
to know what that [__] knew
we need to know this country needs to
[__] know what he [__] knew and
when the [__] he knew it
did he know that his wife was was
was seditiously sexting mark meadows
cueing on conspiracy theories
about how we have to overturn the
[__] constitution in the election the
dually elected president joe biden
and by the way
by the way
the reason why
that jenny thomas didn't want joe biden
to become president
is because she's a [__] racist that's
right i said it
everyone beats around the bush here
because she's married to a black dude
remember the black dude that she's
married to that's the [__] that's the
trope i got a black i'm married to a
black man i can't be i can't yeah you're
married to a black dude
that wants to ostracize black people
from society
get the [__] out of here with that [__]
if they had their fascist state ways
clarence thomas
you piece of [__] [__] i don't know i
don't know what chief justice roberts is
doing this morning but he should really
be [__] evaluating rather the supreme
court has any more legitimacy at this
point his court is is literally
four [__] members of his court
four
the one whose wife who was seditiously
sexting mark meadows the chief of staff
of donald trump who was trying to commit
a cheeto dust kangaroo coup overthrow
the constitution of the united states
which by the way jenny thomas has taken
a note to as a lawyer
by the [__] way
neil gorsuch the first [__] pick of
the of the cheeto dust mobster
brett kavanaugh who was bought and paid
for the same way as they rammed amy
coney barrett down our [__] throat
because she's paid for four of them four
on the court
four
are illegitimate at this point
i'm just saying if there's a reason that
we would need to reevaluate the supreme
court as as one of the most qualified
nominees in the history of nominees
is going to be confirmed because joe
manchin has said he's a yes on her
because there's no other reason why he
can or cannot be if if if
if brown jackson would have gave manchin
a reason he might have considered it but
he didn't and the only reason why we
only need mansion here the only reason
why is because of mitch mcconnell so all
you [__] you trump pumping fools
gonna whine and complain lindsey graham
josh holly tom cotton ted cruz you [__]
are you going to be whining and
complaining and bitching that she gets
confirmed it's because of you ramming
supreme court justices down our throats
i've been saying this for days that
there's
that the supreme court here with these
these hearings with kbj
and now we have clarence thomas's wife
jenny thomas
caught
wide out in the open that she was
seditiously sexting mark meadows to try
to overturn the constitution of the
united states overturn your vote
jenny thomas wanted to take away your
vote because she didn't like how you
decided the election
they're always talking about freedom and
and and liberty and all that [__] they
don't [__] have any goddamn idea what
liberty freedom our rights even
are the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty
and you jenny thomas
are a [__] traitor to the
constitution and to our country
you are a treasonous piece of [__]
because you wanted to overturn the
rights of other people to duly elect the
president of the united states
that's what you did
that's why it's so [__] disgusting
jenny thomas or anyone out there who's
gonna defend her dumb ass
the other thing too
is that if mark meadows wasn't just
receiving text messages this
[__] was sexting back he was
seditiously sexting back
over and over again talking about this
is a fight versus good good versus evil
you god damn right it is you god damn
right it is
it's a fight ver good versus evil we do
not want a fascist state that's why we
elected joe bite i don't believe
that 81 million people
voted for joe biden
there was a hell a lot of that 81
million that voted against fascism
they voted against
trump
they voted against trumpism
that's what they did
81 million [__] in this country
and jenny jenny thomas thinks that she's
she she thinks they're the 81 million
are the elites
oh a [__] elitist
an ivy league educated
wife of a [__] supreme court justice
thinks the 81 million people that voted
for joe biden are the elitist you
[__] [__]
i used that word for marsha blackburn
but god damn
that word is becoming more and more
appropriate this week
for these seditious bastards
thank you kathy for the super chat as
you guys know
we have super chat now and not to switch
switch gears all of a sudden
we have super chat now on the youtube
chat board
you can
contribute to the show thank you kathy
very much for the super chat we really
do
we really do appreciate it here and we
appreciate you guys joining us if you're
new listeners out there we're on every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
youtube twitter twitch and now on the
midas touch facebook page as you know we
are we are proud partners of the midas
touch
organization with the mizellas brothers
ben brett and jordy
thank you fellas for helping us out and
partnering with us
uh we we love we love uh
having you guys here with us
um whether you're on facebook youtube
twitch or twitter
we love having you here
and today is a special day not because
not just because we get to uh
to completely destroy jenny thomas and
clarence thomas
um but because it's bonehead of the week
today is bone end of the week every
friday for those out there who don't
know who are new listeners every single
week we put out a poll on twitter
it's a chance for you to practice
democracy as it were
you know
get your vote in every single week for
bonehead of the week
and holy [__] did we have a lot of
boneheads this week to pick from it was
tough to figure out who was going to go
on the list
but the bonehead of the bonehead of the
boneheaded appears to have won this week
but if you'd like to vote every week
um on the bonehead of the week poll just
go to at tony michael's pod we post it
there every single week we used to post
it earlier in the week but
oh boy it gets tougher and tougher
as the week goes on like i said we
thought the big story this week was
gonna be the manhattan da's office
not acting on what is clear at least the
the former
assistant special district attorney
pomerantz says
is clear evidence of crimes
to hold trump fully accountable
we thought that was going to be the
story which i i keep trumpeting this
nope
keep yelling and screaming this the
former president united states the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
their orange mussolini jesus
is under criminal indictment everyone's
like oh he's not being held accountable
for anything what the hell's going on
why isn't anyone holding him accountable
he is under criminal indictment the
business that he has run
for decades and decades and decades and
the chief financial officer of that
business is under criminal indictment
not only that
the attorney general
likely has the evidence in a civil case
against the trump organization that
pomerant said is clear evidence of
crimes
which would only indicate in the tax
purposes of a civil case i'm not no
[__] lawyer but i would imagine if i
bring a [__] lawyer on which we had
one on yesterday i would imagine
michael popock of legal af i would
imagine if we bring on an attorney here
to tell us about this civil case
that tisch james is going to destroy the
trump organization
that was supposed to be the [__]
story
i was gonna talk about that yesterday we
did yesterday today probably next week
nope
treason is among us treason has entered
the chat
well seditious sexting
that's what i'm calling in here by the
way and someone pointed out on twitter
someone pointed out that
jenny thomas
again who is the wife of a supreme court
justice who is a [__] box
who
apparently just left the hospital the
infection didn't want to win
unfortunately
[__] that i don't care that's what i'm
gonna [__] say [__] him i was rooting
for infection
jenny thomas the wife of the supreme
court justice clarence thomas
was seditiously sexting mark meadows the
chief of staff of the present united
states at the time who was trying to
commit a cheeto dust kangaroo coup who
is donald trump the cheeto dust mobster
all the while mark meadows is committing
voter fraud
by lying about an address so he can vote
in a different state
and then these text messages are like oh
there's so much fraud you need to make
sydney powell the kraken
the [__] leader of this investigation
or some [__] crazy ass [__]
which to be honest with you they they
they completely toyed with the notion
you remember sidney powell and mike
flynn went to the [__] the god damn
the goddamn white house
they were there
they continued to be there
over and over again
even louie gomer and matt gatz and all
these [__] went to petition the
president
to overturn the constitution of the
united states and commit a cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
jesus jenny thomas was urging mark
meadows
to force the vice president united
states to do something that he did not
have the power to do
which is laid out the whole plan was
laid out in the [__] eastman memo
now a lot of people this week are going
to say oh my god the january six select
committee is doing nothing their hand
they're not doing anything
come on
get [__] real
you think that they're going to be able
to not do anything you think the
department of justice the word is today
oh merrick garland merrick garland must
must
you think the department of justice
isn't going to act
i think i think the house of
representatives should act on clarence
thomas's behalf of his impeachment
if there's evidence that he knew and he
was participating in this q a on garbage
to overturn the constitution in the
united states which he has taken several
[__] oaths for and two
one specifically
to his position to the supreme court of
the united states [__] that guy impeach
him now or resign [__]
let's confirm kbj
to justice breyer's seat
and let's put another black woman as a
nominee let's do that
actually
which i'm fine with but can you imagine
can you imagine
what the great the greatest hearing in
the [__] world the greatest hearings
in the world
would be if joe biden nominated barack
obama
to be the supreme court justice
replacement
for clarence thomas holy [__] [__]
can you believe can you can you ima can
you can you imagine watching barack
obama
destroying josh hawley
destroying ted cruz absolutely gutting
tom cotton can you even i mean i
wouldn't even care if he didn't win the
[__] vote
i would pay money
to watch
that confirmation hearing on the
judiciary committee
to watch lindsey graham
just eat his [__] sandwich as barack
obama feeds it up to him oh that would
be fantastic
absolutely fantastic and phenomenal
and joe biden i i don't know i don't
know if the president united states
listens to my show i'm guessing he he
probably
i think we we surmised this yesterday
anyways
i i don't think he does but if he did if
he did joe joe come on throw us a bone
we just want to see even if he doesn't
pass the vote we just want to see
that confirmation hearing
with barack obama
absolutely destroying these republican
senators
okay gail thank you very much for the
super
the super chat we really appreciate it
thank you very much everyone everyone
give gayle some love in the chat there
give her some fire thank you very much
for the super chat as you guys know we
are on youtube twitter twitch every
weekday noon eastern 11 central
and now we're on facebook
broadcasting live from the midas touch
page
so check us out there check us out here
go follow us like you know all that kind
of good stuff
like subscribe whatever whatever this
stuff i'm supposed to say you know i'm
i'm supposed to say like subscribe and
comment down below point to the to the
comments that you know i'm i'm
i'm not that great of a youtuber i guess
i watch my kids they do these did the
videos and at the end of the videos like
okay yeah see you later like and
subscribe and don't forget to comment
and come back i don't know i i don't
know
i don't know
oh man
boy you guys are really on fire today in
the chat on facebook and and youtube
uh let's see if we can get some shout
outs here we have uh
uh we have stacy from facebook
uh uh
jackie from facebook david's here
kelly's here mj's here
um crystal is here from facebook
freddie's here from facebook welcome
welcome everyone hello good morning
um we have some out there listening on
twitch
jimmy's here on facebook
[Music]
let's see we have kalyn here on youtube
uh
kathy's here christina's here
we have everyone here keep coming back
every single day
go go also you can listen to the podcast
on apple spotify the the most boycotted
directory and all your favorite
directories give us a five star review
when you're over there
good news today
is we have bone end of the week we have
bone end of the week
today
gabe's gonna join us uh he might join us
a little early before we do bonehead uh
so we can talk a little bit about the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
which i want to go to right after this
break stick around don't go anywhere
right after this we'll do the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends we'll be
right back
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bob
dear bob i'm fixing to send you some
more of them doritos you like the red
bag not the lid loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[__] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining us
on this great friday
as we do every friday every single
weekday
right here on youtube twitter and twitch
and now they might just facebook page
let's go to the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends and we got a lot of stuff
to get to today not just not just the
jenny uh thomas
debacle
with the seditious sexting but we also
we also have um some news
about mansion
and kbj
you know some different supreme court
news there's appears to be uh breaking
news from
what is being called icon park i guess
in orlando
um some unfortunate news it seems like
uh so we'll we'll probably go over that
now we also let's see what else what
else do we have today what else do we
have today bob woodward of course is in
the trends because of his story
kim jong-un is in the trends
probably because he's making the cheeto
dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
very very jealous
let's see some other things that worked
into the trends the white house chief of
staff is trending
let's see what else do we have we got a
lot of stuff going on today
but in politics
it seems as if
the the seditious sexting of jenny
thomas to mark meadows has taken over
everything because chief justice roberts
is trending rand paul was trending for a
little bit so we'll find out um
why rand paul was trending and why we
all wish we could be
his neighbor
won't you be my neighbor
so let's go to the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends
let's start the countdown
[Music]
so
the [__] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the part
of the show that we call the [__] list
roundup where we round up all the tweety
tweets and attorney trends and we go
through the news of the day we go
through the news of the day we got
someone here on facebook that is very
upset
and i want to point it out he's trying
to he's he wants his he wants attention
he wants attention here steve steve's
gets some attention he says you make
midas touch lose all integrity and
dignity intelligence
great show to watch if anyone wants to
learn cheeto dust ramming goddamn
[__] words
and then and then he says uh he says
here and steve steve stick around man
stick around man you're gonna really
enjoy the show he asked how he can block
i mean you can block me if you want i
mean it doesn't matter you don't have to
watch you can keep scrolling steve
you can keep showing and that's how we
can block this idiot
you could ski
steve steve listen listen i appreciate
you being here i please i appreciate you
listening and i'm glad that you stuck
around for this long
it is it is really really nice that you
have stayed this long i mean we're 30
minutes into the hour steve
i really appreciate that you stuck
around this long i hope that you'll come
back every single day
every single day and keep watching
noon eastern 11 central
youtube twitter twitch and now
now on
the midas touch facebook page much to
steve chagrin but steve stick around
don't scroll don't keep scrolling
keep
listening keep listening steve it's more
than just the f word there's a lot of
them there's a lot he says
he says well thank you i will thank you
steve thank you for listening thank you
for being here thank you for giving me
the opportunity to show you that there's
more there's more to me than just the f
word
there's more to me than just look here's
chris in see chris n throws in chris n
is a hate watcher we we love thank you
chris for being here
we don't get rid we don't just get rid
of trolls around here we like troll we
love we love
when people have a problem
with what we're saying
we love it
it's about high time in this country
that the left
the democrats the libtards
as it were
start offending people
the correct people that is
stop you know being like gloved you want
to get in the fight
the fight is
these fascists are trying to take over
our country and they're trying to
overturn
our constitution they want our
government and they want it to be an
autocracy that's what they want they
want it to be a fascist state
and if that means we got to throw around
a few [__] f words to get people's
attention to make sure that they're
paying attention to what the [__] is
happening in the country that it's being
taken away from them that everything
they know their job their church their
school
their community center their health care
everything they know and love and they
don't even
have the appreciation for can all be
swept away
by autocracy
and totalitarianism
i don't know if we uh if we forgot
what's happening in ukraine but russia
continues to attack key cities in
ukraine
bombing them killing innocent civilians
the vladimir putin is not going to stop
his destruction of democracy he's gone
too far
to turn back now
you don't think that the republican
party the gqp in this country
you don't think that they don't want
what putin wants for ukraine in our
country
you don't think
come on
they would they would love
they would love
to get rid of the lgbt community in this
country absolutely love it
they would they would
they would grab it the chance
we've seen the indiana senator mike
braun that [__] box
advocate
to get rid of interracial marriages in
states it's a state's rights
and you got to read between their white
white privileged language here
because what they're saying is they want
two americas this is the cheeto dust
confederacy that's what they want they
want to develop two americas
they want a fascist state
and they want democracy to go somewhere
else
you don't like fascism well take your
democracy somewhere else get out of
florida get the hell out of texas
you can't be gay here you can't be trans
here oh you want to have an interracial
marriage get the [__] out of indiana
that's what they're saying
mark my words
and if a few little f words
are gonna get in the way of us making
them pay attention
and by them i mean the people who need
to pay attention that just because
donald trump is no longer the president
doesn't mean these people aren't still
trying to commit a coup doesn't mean
they're still trying to take over our
country doesn't mean they're trying to
topple our constitution it doesn't mean
that they want they don't want a fascist
state they do they will and they're
coming
they're marching
mj thank you for the twenty dollars
dedicated to steve she says
i'm guessing steve on uh on facebook
now steve i i really do hope you stick
around
uh digger dog adventures
also has a super chat thank you very
much everyone in the chat when someone
gives a super chat make sure to thank
them give them some fire give them some
love
in the chat we do appreciate
we do appreciate
all the super chats over on youtube
thank you very much for supporting the
show let's get to the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends let's start on the
timeline
here
oh
see i don't know how to run the controls
i guess
that's 35 minutes into the hour we're
gonna we're gonna do bone head of the
week in the second hour but we're gonna
go through some tweety sweets attorney
trends here um our co-host and executive
producer gabe sanchez
tweeted this out earlier
excuse me
um
need some water there some water
need to get some water
gabe tweeted us out the thomas timeline
this is the timeline of
uh jenny and clarence thomas
on 119
2022 clarence thomas's loan descent and
trump's bid to withhold white house
documents you guys remember this
donald trump was trying to withhold
white house documents
from the select committee
him and steve bannon
and the supreme court court said no but
the loan vote was clarence thomas
clarence thomas did say well it might be
okay
3 18 just a few days ago clarence thomas
was quote unquote hospitalized with an
infection as was the report
i was rooting
for infection
in that in that rig in that story you
know i'm just saying whatever
um 3 24 this was yesterday
jenny thomas's seditious text
i call it sexting seditious sexting with
mark meadows leaked
that leaked through the story with bob
woodward and bob costa in the washington
post
which we will probably go read some of
those today
i'm schiller
and then today 3 25 20 22 just today
clarence thomas is released
from the hospital hmm this all seems
convenient
it all seems convenient
hmm
gabe actually in the reply he says and
you guys can vote but i wanted to vote
live here he says what comes next in the
timeline he's impeached he's resigned or
nothing happens
well at this point i want to say nothing
happens so did 83 percent of people
um if you if you would have asked gabe
if gabe if you would've asked
um what should happen
what should happen i would have said
um well my first
inclination was the
infection but he's impeached i would
like i don't want him to resign
i don't want him to resign i think now
to resign would be way too [__] easy
way
too easy
i'm gonna retweet this so you guys can
go find this poll that gabe put up
and don't don't let the vote here skew
your opinion but um
i think everyone's spot on here of what
uh what's gonna happen
um
lance says here uh we need senators who
will adhere to the text of our
constitution not incite insurrections to
overthrow democracy i think he's talking
about um some of these senators that are
questioning kbj
um honestly i think that's what he's
talking about that's what i think we
should have
sorry clarence thomas mayo says but a
doctor's note won't excuse you and jenny
from being investigated paris edition um
you know we've talked a lot about and
had a lot of guests on this show
about the seditious conspiracy that is
um the oath keepers and the proud boys
and we talked a lot about that that that
fact
and uh maybe just maybe that conspiracy
will we reach other tentacles because
here's the thing
here's the thing in these in this
seditious sexting that ginny thomas was
doing with mark meadows
sheep drops the name sydney powell
and i don't know if you remember sydney
pal the kraken as it were
but sydney powell
sydney powell
is uh
it was mike flynn's
lawyer
in his federal case before donald trump
pardoned him that's right
donald trump pardoned him
now sydney powell also has connections
to rudy giuliani if you remember the uh
the press conference where rudy giuliani
where the [__] was running out of his
brains you remember that where the [__]
was running down his face
ready a [__] for brains was running all
the way down his temples
sydney powell was at that press
conference right
she was at that one she said some crazy
ass [__] [__] at that press
conference
so crazy in fact that rudy giuliani and
donald trump himself were like whoa
this one has lost her [__] marbles
wouldn't let her reappear
as council and basically said sydney
powell is not
any pal we don't even know who that is
we're not even sure if she goes and gets
coffee for anyone
that's right
they cast out cindy powell
at that point
you remember this
but sydney powell also has ties
to len wood
do you remember who lin wood is
this guy's nuttier than [__] squirrel
turds
running around the country telling
everyone that these these q and on
meetings that somehow donald trump is
anointed by jesus and god and somehow
jesus and god is going to save them and
make donald trump the king of the castle
or some i don't know some crazy ass [__]
some crazy ass q anon stuff
cult stuff they're part of the cult
they're the crt jfk junior cult it's the
same [__]
the same [__]
so do these tentacles reach
reach to people like roger stone that on
the day
of january 6 which we know jenny thomas
paid
paid for to bust in people to the
insurrection we know that we know that
for a fact
and roger stone was there with the oath
keepers
he had protection from the oath keepers
which his original protection detail was
supposed to be from the proud boys
which we see that enrique tario who was
supposed to be the leader of the proud
boys who was banned from the city of dc
at the time for crimes that he committed
he was not allowed to enter this
entered the city but he did anyways to
meet with stuart rhodes
the founder of the oath keepers in a
parking garage
to have a pow-wow about their seditious
conspiracy
and we see on the day of jan that was
january 5th the day before january 6
where we see that roger stone had joshua
james an oath keeper
one of the 11 that was also charged
during the time that stuart rose was
also charged with conditions seditious
conspiracy
has now
pled guilty in a federal court to it
the person who was standing right next
to roger stone that very day
so
let's just let's just put
a pin in all these little seditious
acts
and understand
that these jenny thomas emails
aren't some kind of [__] one-off
they're not a one-off
why do you think she was so close to
sydney powell wanting cindy powell to be
the leader of the [__] investigation
or some [__]
who knows who knows
what these crazy ass people
missed one thank you very much for the
super chat we won't tell anyone
that you're watching the tony michaels
podcast instead of how sh
don't tell anyone missed one says
missed one must be a sparkler
shout out to all the sparklers out there
that come and listen to the tony
michaels podcast you're welcome here
anytime and while you're over there
talking to hal make sure you tell hal to
come on the show i'd love to have a hell
on the show i know me and hal could hash
some of this stuff out
we have a lot of the same views maybe
not from the same perspective
but i think me and hal match up a bit we
like to clown these folks they're clowns
and they're totally clownable
right
holy [__] are they easy to clown i mean
really they kind of do your job for you
again how could you not call what jenny
thomas is doing with mark meadows
seditious sexting it fits perfect
together those words fit perfect
together seditious sexting
they fit perfect to get i'm not gonna do
that
come on
what am i five
six
i think this is this is what steve was
steve was talking about earlier
seems a little oh steve thank you very
much he says it's a huge improvement
well see if you stick around for a while
and you get past a few of the curse
words the kissing
and the announcements you know
it gets a little better
thank you stephen
keep tuning in every single weekday
steve
every single weekend look if you guys
don't get a chance to to watch the live
videos don't
don't
rattle yourself
these episodes are on youtube
just go subscribe you can search the
tony michael's podcast on youtube you
can find it
you can go to twitter
you can search me on instagram or
facebook
but they're out there also on all the
directories apple spotify google your
favorite directory and while you're all
those places whether it's facebook
instagram give us some likes give us a
five star review we'd really appreciate
it and if you're a new listener go get
caught up on a few of the episodes
we had some great guests we had a great
guest on yesterday which was bad brad
berkwit and last week we had anthony
scaramucci the mooch
so go watch some of those
episodes or listen to some of those
episodes
as well because we're going to be here
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central okay let's get back to the tweet
tweets and the trendy trends here i'll
get off my soapbox we'll get back on
here in a minute i promise um
dan here tweets
earlier about joe manchin
he says joe manchin intends to vote for
judge katanji brown jackson all but
ensuring her scotus nomination which is
the truth because of the republicans did
away with the filibuster to carve out
carve out the filibuster just for
supreme court justices which they should
do for everything including voting
rights they won't because they're weak
weak pieces of [__] but that you know
joe manchin here
is doing what he what everyone knew he
would do
is vote for kbj
um there's no
if trust me if joe manchin had a reason
to vote against kg
kbj he would he would do it and what i
mean by that is if he thought that his
vote was going to hurt him in west
virginia he vote against her but he
can't he won't because there's no way
that this vote is going to hurt him
anywhere
she's one of the most qualified if not
the most qualified person to ever be
nominated to a supreme court seat
ever the reason why is because she's a
black woman
let me explain black women have to women
have to work about a hundred times
harder than men in this country black
women have to work just as that much
harder they're one of the most educated
demographics in this country
because they have to be
to get where they are
kbj
didn't get where she's at
because she's black
she got where she's at because
she's black and she had to work her ass
off and prove herself time and time
again to white wrinkly old ball sacks
like she had to [__] endure
for the entire week in the nomination
hearings
these [__] scumbags
dan says here he's
joe manchin
he's finally in the news cycle for
something good
joe manchin is doing something good
should we give him credit fine whatever
okay let's give him credit in other news
pigs fly and hell is freezing over
[Laughter]
thank you dan for giving this the uh the
laughter and the dismount there uh i
want you guys to welcome
our co-host
and executive producer gabe sanchez gabe
how are you i'm good microphone and all
michael
i'm rocking it baby yeah that's good
that's good welcome welcome to the show
it's a good show today there's a lot of
[__] to talk about my god is there a lot
of [__] this week really ramp like
you know that scene in jurassic park
where jeff bull bloom like he walks up
and he takes a glass and he's like
that's a big pile of [__]
that's what this week turned into like
that that gif that gif of that is like
that's the description of this week
right
yeah and uh
yeah there's a lot of [__] going on too
um i mean look look at this look at my
timeline here i'm not even to the trendy
twins on tweety tweets yet and i'm
trying to find a video that someone may
or may or may not have posted that
they're
where they're reading some of these uh
uh sext messages i've been calling them
seditious sext messages
i mean see that's i made that joke i
made a joke about that yesterday where
it was like clarence thomas he goes uh
it was like you know clarence thomas uh
or the news breaks that jenny thomas
has uh has been sending mark meadows
texts about
um
about overturning the election and the
first thing clarence thomas goes
thought she was having an affair
all right second one is
how much to stay longer at the hospital
you know yeah right right right well
yeah because he definitely well i mean
he was released today that's what they
say who knows but look at this we got we
got madison cawthorne here accepting uh
uh funds he's taking credit right right
right now for the infrastructure bill
that he voted against yeah um and
there's this [__] guy jeff jeff uh
fortenberry you get this is
a
a sitting congressman from nebraska i
believe who was just uh yesterday found
guilty of uh lying to the fbi is he the
one that made the donation or took the
money yeah so i was wondering who this
guy was and then um i took this video
and i'm like oh it's this [__] guy he
made this video from his truck with his
wife here let's just watch it f100
pickup truck with our dog pippin and
this is my wife oh yeah pippin oh
there's a dog
i wanted to send you a video because we
do have something hard to tell you
he has something really hard to tell he
wants to tell his uh his supporters out
there how he's a [__] he lied to the
fbi because he knew that he was taking
born funds and then he lied about it but
he thought he could lie about it because
he's a white male congressman from
nebraska his hair his hair kind of looks
like my wig
it i i oh my god
when i when i seen this video earlier
and i posted i was like gabe has this
exact same hair
he's got this exact same hair in his
closet i was i almost tweeted it even
yeah well you don't even tweeted it you
know there's a video online and it's i'm
you know i could who knows i could pass
as uh
but it's an issue i've never heard it
before right well let's let's listen to
what he says about about the fbi agent
was through the years and
tweeted us about five and a half years
ago a person from overseas illegally
moved money to my campaign i love how he
says he moved money right like yeah like
i i got it right right
it was like five dollars right like get
the [__] out of here
you moved you moved i didn't i didn't
wire your money to pay rent this guy
wired thousands of dollars to influence
you as a candidate and uh a sitting
member of of congress right the [__] up
right here listen i don't know anything
about this
some other americans not a goddamn thing
they were all caught and punished
thankfully and you are about two and a
half years ago i had a knock on my door
i had been out dealing with the effects
of the bomb cyclone that that had hit us
which was so devastatingly hard which
i'm not sure if any of that's true like
the bombs and that might be true i mean
he is a congress person that may have
been like but i'm not sure like
this is in uh nebraska yeah yeah that's
that's what he's saying i'm not sure if
that's true but but i'm gonna call a
meteorologist
right right well maybe we should have
one on the show to confirm this but
listen listen to what he says
about the fbi agents listen this is this
is fantastic because what he's trying to
do is delegitimize him listen our star
communities
they were fbi agents from california
what like what what they're the federal
bureau of investment yeah like it
doesn't matter like
oh
right and it's a it's a federal charge
it's like it doesn't matter where the
[__] they're from but they're from
california from a different country
really can you believe that they were
coming and questioning me about foreign
money that i had moved
i mean you know conveniently in my
account and these these foreigners from
california it's not california it's
california
[Laughter]
is that what it is the communist state
of california yeah i live in the state
of california oh okay good uh good and
it's it's pretty great out here i mean
kind of expensive but pretty great
well i'm not gonna i'm not gonna finish
this up he basically says uh they
accused me of lying of course i lied why
wouldn't i lie i mean i'm white i i i
mean i don't know i mean he he was
convicted yesterday yeah it's like what
would you do in this situation right i
don't know maybe
not lie right right i forgot about this
guy though until i until i seen this
video i'm like oh so i said who's jeff
fortenberry oh yeah this [__] guy
should it be like jeff fort and perjury
yeah there you go that's what it is yeah
yeah good good nickname good good
alley-oop
uh so also also another thing that we
don't get talking about
which we are going to talk about right
now is mo brooks this is a short clip
let's listen to
um no mo brooks as uh mayo called him
yesterday i say mo brooks mo problems
yeah and as trump says woke mo brooks
woke
listen
listen to why how mo brooks woke up and
realized he didn't want to go to federal
prison for seditious conspiracy listen
to how wokey is um the president has
asked me to rescind the election
he still calls him the president not not
the former
like like he's still he's still so in
the mode like he's so woke that he can't
eat you know anyways let's listen 20 20
that's you say that's right it's you
can't do that what did he ask you and
what did you tell him well he he always
brings up we've got to rescind the
election we got to take joe biden out
and put me in now he still says that yes
well yeah because he's under indictment
in new york and he's he's possibly going
to be charged with seditious conspiracy
in the january 6 insurrection here i i
love that mo brooks over here who is a
sitting uh member of congress
uh is is saying oh you know what
president trump tried to get me to
rescind the election and i said no
however
i did tell everyone right to [__]
fight and kick
and i was up on that stage
take names right yeah exactly and uh you
know it was a peaceful protest yet you
wore a bulletproof vest that day
underneath your clothing uh for a stop
the steel rally to go make
the uh
the um
capitol hill
uh not certify the election so don't
come at
like don't try to [__] revision this
whole moment and say you know what from
the very beginning i've been telling
trump that he cannot rescind the
election if that was true you would have
never have been on stage at the rally
riling everybody up to go you know
decertify the election and force their
way into the capital it's like don't
don't try to play that dude we we have
literal receipts of you on stage of
things you said in interviews
let's let's see if let's see if he's
still wearing his bulletproof vest here
let's see i'm going mr president i'm
giving him advice i'm an attorney i've
read the law i've read the constitution
i know have you and i've seen this
present
he's read it now unlike marsha blackburn
he's read the constitution maybe he
hasn't read the declaration of
independence though i don't know maybe
right right obviously
i have a hard time believing any of them
have read you know when they're like i
read the constitution you you read it
all really you read the whole thing you
read ever line by line you could recite
it right now like this is a goddamn
shakespeare play no no you didn't you
said you did and you only know a couple
words here and there
the main one being the constitution
uh you well they like those words those
are good words constitution you know
freedom liberty they like to pepper
those in you know
like marsha blackburn does she's like
liberty abortion like like she just
woman
right you know what it reminds me of
it's like uh it's like trump when it's
like tv man camera it's like woman
constitution
crt right abortion yeah abortion
abortion abortion can't do that it's
unconstitutional and there is a choice
between donald trump yeah who i respect
he had a lot of great policies
i am always going to choose the
constitution because that's what youth
of office is too sure about that and i
knew that when i gave him straight
shooting legal advice um
that it would perturb him because it's
not what he wanted to hear and i knew it
would put my endorsement at risk but so
this seems like to me this seems like to
me when when mo brooks because here's
what i said i said mo brooks no problem
by the way [__] him um
because here's what it seems like to me
it's like mo brooks knows he's in big
[__] trouble yep and they know
they're in big trouble with these text
messages and everything that january 6
select committee has
and and what is going to be because you
know if january 6 select committee has a
doj has that [__] or will get that oh
one way or the other these [__]
know they're in big trouble so they want
to be on the record
on tv saying no absolutely not i'm not
i'm not treasonous hell to the no it
wasn't me
one me who was committing sedition
yeah yeah get the [__] out of here the
only problem with that
go ahead go ahead probably the only
problem with that narrative or that that
type of uh messaging is the fact that
you you [__] did it you can't you
can't after the fact it's like right
the dog did this and it's like we have
you on camera literally throwing the
trash around the kitchen and like it
wasn't it wasn't me why would i do it
right then you can have text messages of
each other like hey should we should we
actually tear the trash can up in the
kitchen and how should we do it oh and
then after the fact they're like no no
it was all wrong we shouldn't have done
it that way we should have done it this
way yeah i know speaking of [__]
idiots here's tulsi gabbard i'm not even
gonna believe this sean hannity has to
[__] tell her how dumb she is this is
getting ridiculous this is one way when
i saw this last night i sent you the
message and i was like god damn it
i was like this is a moment where i
actually agree with sean hannity about
like we have a russian agent aka
chelsea gabbard who is on the show now i
don't have to say that that uh hannity
isn't some russian agent as well but
uh yet to be determined
but the fact that she's in there and
she's like they just gotta give up they
just gotta stop they just they they you
know it's fine we gotta win stop giving
them false hope
that's how wars work right look right
that's how wars work i said tulsi
garrett is such a marsha blackburn i'm
gonna use marsha blackburn as a as a
playsetter for a certain c word that i
called her the other day marsha black is
such a marsha blackburn um
this is a good one
i'm gonna
telling my kids this is jenny thomas
i know i know we're gonna get to this i
know we're gonna get to this um in the
bonehead here really soon as we enter
the second hour do you think i i think
this is a photo of jenny thomas when she
finds a sale at like uh at pier one
important wow
yeah
fifty percent uh are the seditious
pillars on sale are the trees and his
pillows on sale you got to see though
you got to see what hoodlum posted
i'm here let's see if i can find it
ah here it is
hoodlum posted this picture
[Laughter]
he's the same photo
oh my god
uh
you know
it really is not that humorous that this
that the a wife
the wife
of a supreme court justice yeah
who in fact had a say in rather the
records from january 6 would be withheld
from a committee who's trying to
investigate the overthrowing of our
government right
and he voted for them not to have those
records
you know i
there there's a question i have about
her role in uh her role and her
influence on clarence thomas which is
how many other
moments in time
did he you know
uh
you know give a descent or or uh
or
opine on some case or whatever that was
a direct result of something ginny said
in the house right right cause she said
in a she said in in a quote or an
article she's like clarence doesn't
bring work home with him so we don't
discuss that
i'm gonna have to say uh a hard [__]
[__] on that one because
i can't take anything jenny says to be
serious right because i i feel like any
credibility if there was any at all has
been taken away by the fact that she was
you know
sexting so she's a cuban honor not only
not only
not only was she doing all that the
thing that and maybe it's it's um
it's tough to uncouple some of this
stuff right but
she
she believes the q and on stuff hook
line sinker like i would not be
surprised if she's a jfk junior's coming
back to life type [__] oh hands down i
mean imagine imagine being
a fly on the wall
in that house right like at dinner
doing laundry watching tv
like the types of conversations
because i have a hard time thinking that
she doesn't just drop some [__] cue
[__] into a thing and either clarence
thomas is like
oh god not again like he's like stuck in
this or
he goes
because i'm like okay
i don't know what the relationship's
like so i can't really comment on that
but what i will say is that uh either
one he has accepted
these conspiracies and does not dismiss
what she says right or
you know for whatever reason he's more
or less stuck in this relationship for
maybe uh the the way it comes across as
an image or the way that he actually
feels you know but
if she said this stuff you know is he
responding with like a eye roll or is he
responding with uh yeah no i totally
agree jenny like it's one of the other
because obviously one of those
i mean they're both bad signs but right
he's accepting the fact that she's he's
going apps so [__] loot right yes
yes
that is a cause for concern
for
anything that he touches on the bench
right right and uh i think it's safe to
say
that republicans
have lost this is why we can't have nice
things republicans have lost all
say and all nominations and votes when
it comes to
uh the supreme court because as we know
republicans [__] [__] up for everyone uh
that's below them right
constituents [__] them
other politicians [__] them right like
just the general uh state of democracy
in this country
[__] them because that's what it is and
that's and that's what they do and then
you know of course they're like oh
trickle down economics or gaslighting
this or i didn't you know madison
carthage you don't know how crude prices
work right exactly kinds of [__]
well so here's a video that was found on
the internet by you said dramatic
reading of uh i want to call seditious
sex messages um sent to mark meadows
from jenny thomas so hang with us
i could see i just
i could see an alternative take on this
video which is uh
which is almost
it it's like that those like late night
commercials where it's like looking to
find a friend
do you feel lonely at night
make sure to text your best friend you
know because she talks about a best
friend by the way right but in the video
it's like make sure to
you know call or text the number
900-881-5641 i don't know if that's a
real number okay i don't know if it's a
real night don't call that [__]
number that is not jimmy thomas's number
gabe does not well
you get calls from like don junior and
bobert so maybe you do right they
somehow keep getting my number right you
know they got it out there but yes that
is one of those things where i could see
it work like a whole different take
would be
the like very sensual like erotic kind
of thing
yeah yeah you know rosy rosy colored uh
uh like you know kind of look and feel
on a silk
silk bed you know and there's like one
of those like sex novels you know that
you get uh yeah so i that's what i took
i could see an alternative if someone
were to do that you know i could see
that i don't know if i will so if
someone else wants to right well stick
stick around because uh right after this
break we're going to bring you bonehead
of the week and i think jenny thomas
makes a an appearance even though she
wasn't on the pole
she's the late she's a late one she does
make an appearance
uh on the bonehead of the week so stick
around right after these messages we'll
go through the bone head of the weak
pole we'll go through your vote for bone
head of the week stick around we'll be
right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the drip lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [__] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we are we are into the second hour on
friday and you know what that means we
are now going to
go through your vote of the poll of
bonehead of the week gabe are you ready
for bone hand of the week i am ready did
you see that transition i'm getting
better and blessed
right into the bone end of the week we
need to change the look of this i know i
haven't we're still on
i have it on my computer i need to just
export and put in uh incentive oh oh so
it's there
yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay well you know that
explains it next week next week new look
oh yeah new look on bone of the week so
don't forget every single friday um the
second hour of the show noon eastern 11
central the second hour of the show on
fridays we go through your vote on the
bonehead of the week poll
that is found at tony michael's pod on
twitter just go to tonymichaelspod
follow us there also follow me at the
tony michaels and follow gabe at i am
gabe sanchez
and and then you can put your
your two cents in your five cents and
your ten sometimes it's like a half cent
sometimes you know yeah we put in a
whole dollar right right right you ain't
got much to put in for these boneheads
right [__] boneheads so let's get to
the bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week
i will i will say this i'll make i'll do
a reminder at the end but
uh i didn't want to confuse people with
the bonehead madness pull
so the bonehead madness pull there will
be four pulls or maybe two today and two
tomorrow okay but um
there are different groups there's the
us senators there's the u.s
representatives there's the lame stream
media and then there's this other group
that i haven't given a name for but they
just might be called others okay but not
to cause confusion between our current
week's poll and the bonehead madness
poll that'll just run over the next like
week before the next week
uh i wanted to i wanted to hold off okay
good so so just so everyone understands
we have the bonehead of the week poll
where we have three contestants every
single week that we pick for bonehead of
the week and then you guys vote and then
we go through the vote here on the tony
michaels podcast on friday but gabe has
a special game that he's going to play
and again we want to make sure that we
don't get in any kind of copyrights over
here because it's called bonehead
madness right you don't want it to be
confused because it's in mar it is in
march right right right like a bracket
thing it's not this is not
this is not for sure
not
right it's not
not madness
right because we we can't actually say
that or bring that up because we might
have infringement so we want to make
sure clear that it's bonehead madness
not march madness right bonehead right
correct even though it is in march and
it may appear but that is not what it is
exactly it's cbs right that we'll get in
trouble yeah okay
um well maybe i'll have to have poc back
on the show to help us with our season
assist
as i as i say oh or not uh you know
right but i will say the names i came up
with for the different brackets i'm
starting at the sweet 16 just because
i wanted to keep it simple uh it's the
sinister 16 okay the uh hateful eight
okay and the deplorable four
uh perfect yeah perfect and then and
then what's the champion what's the
championship the is there have we come
up with that name yet i haven't had
anything on that yeah yeah i'll think on
that we'll think on that um so here is
here here is the the poll that we had um
for
the bonehead of the week this week our
contestants were all three senators
um which was pretty easy with the kbj
nomination hearings this week they all
they all threw their hat in the ring oh
my gosh and really honestly we could
have had six on here we gotta had
corning on here cotton on here um holly
right holly could have been on here um
did any of them any rep mike lee could
have been on here really the only one
that didn't do bone-headed [__] was ben
sass and ben sass is like um
our my republican colleagues here are a
bunch of [__] boneheads as ted cruz
sits there and sips his diet doctor yeah
the best yeah the best part is like some
of these [__] are just this guy
this [__] guy perfect shot i'll also
have him over the shoulder as he just
sits there you know ted cruz but it is
it is one of those things where it's
like oh my god it was a good a good hit
to be like yeah some of these other
people here are what do you call
jackassery i think was the name
they participate in jackassery or
maybe maybe he said because what he was
talking about was and maybe we'll we'll
play the clip um because ted cruz is on
the pole and ted cruz was sitting in the
clip which is fantastic to watch his
look on his face in between the moments
of him searching for his name on twitter
by the way right exactly but but what he
was what ben senator ben sasse was
talking about was that the cameras to be
allowed in the supreme court to record
it what he's saying is is that
people will take the opportunity to make
clips for fox news and do a bunch of
jackasseries so that way they can get on
the news so that's that's that's right
and then of course right after
in in in the uh rotunda
area you know
uh
of course they had their they had their
little
fox news
jackassery session exactly right right
so here is here is our contestants
i i'm sorry i i can't
i can't help but
gabe always picks the the best pictures
here of um these these folks but the
lindsey graham one is
fantastic where did you find
i don't know i forgot i was licking his
lips always yeah let me if i
you know always looking there's always
something i'm looking for which is like
like someone and i'm like sad gum
stupid face you know those are all
things that i like type in as as like
modifiers uh i don't know
uh if i just if i knew what i was
looking for i might have just for like
lindsey graham lick lips and you'd be
surprised how many oh yes i know where i
got it from
uh it was from
uh was he was he around trump like was
he in his vicinity it was he was doing
this january 25th 2019. so trump i don't
know if he was still there but it was
lindsey graham claims uh aoc is
hell-bent on americans becoming
venezuelan socialists
uh and that was the photo they used i
don't know if that was playing the event
but
uh yeah
yeah sloppy and sloppy
seditious sloppy seconds right yeah well
you know he is uh he is a [__]
bonehead um so
let's let's go to the lindsey graham
feed here um though now
obviously the reason why lindsey graham
is uh bonehead of the are on the
bonehead of the week poll is because of
his
uh his disgraceful actions that he did
inside the kbj
the judge brown jackson nomination
hearings when he cried about how brett
kavanaugh didn't get a fair hearing oh
yeah and how uh katangi brown jackson
was because she's a black woman them
white men are just mistreated you know
how in the world how in the world can
you accuse someone who's accused of
sexual assault and have to ask him
questions why can't we ask you those
questions miss miss brown jackson why
can't we ask you about how you were
partying in college and raping other
people because she didn't that's why
that's why you can't answer this
question the other thing too is you know
he goes in on her uh about religion
right and how faithful are you on a
scale of one to ten right and then he
goes which i'm like it's the same thing
as uh
uh who is it tillis who is like i'm no
legal i'm the lawyer but i watch law and
order
there's another [__] bonehead
i know that one yeah that that that
remark was uh
remarkable really yeah it was remarkable
really it was remarkable but for lindsey
graham you know he goes at at uh at her
to say you know how faithful are you are
you are you a person of faith she's like
oh my protestant you know whatever and
she talks about it she's like oh how my
faith is again should not have an
influence well but she was like what the
hell does this have to do with it right
right it doesn't happen
and then she goes you know doesn't have
an influence doesn't have anything to do
with this but she can't say that because
of the perception that it would have
which i which is complete [__] all
these guys like ted cruz and lindsey
graham and all them who come at her you
know she can't
refu she can't do any sort of combative
rebuttal because again she'll come off
as uh unprofessional or or emotional or
all these all these things like oh she's
the angry black woman like those are the
things that they'll pin against her and
they'll be like that's the reason why we
didn't want to vote for her it's like no
no you don't want him over it because
she was black and because you're racist
you just try to make an excuse to
justify it but lindsey graham over here
is using faith you know
faith to come in and say well how how
faithful are you on a scale of one to
ten like how religious you know and he's
like now me i'm lower on the scale i
probably go to church like three times a
year then what the [__] does it matter
right why do you care well here's why he
cares here's why he cares it's the same
reason why he cared about whether he
could accuse her of having a of sexual
assault because she has never
she he can't ask any questions to
katanji brown jackson about sexual
assault because she's never committed
sexual assault it's the same thing about
amy coney barrett when amy coney barrett
uses her religious dogma to hide her
bigotry she hides her bigotry
and and how she wants to oppress the
liberty of people behind her religion
and so democrats had to ask her about
that brown jackson judge brown jackson
has never
hid her bigotry or wanting to oppress or
subvert the constitution behind her
religious dogma she's never done that
not in a decision not in any kind of
[__] public statement she has never
ever ever
wanted to take away americans liberty or
even hinted at that right and hid behind
her religious dog and hid that behind
her religious dogma amy coney barrett
did over and over and over and over
again because she uses her religious
dogma to hide her her
bigotry and and
her desire for oppressing the rights of
other people and oppressing people's
liberty she does that with abortion and
all sorts of things we don't need to go
into that now but that's what lindsey
graham was talking about i do want to
play this video that joey post i
actually posted this i think on
instagram and twitter and uh people love
this video lindsey
and it really
the thing i like about this video is it
pisses off everybody like it pisses off
lefties it pisses off trumpers it pisses
off everyone when they watch this video
because lindsey graham is just yeah he's
a scumbag let's let's watch part of this
i'm not going to watch the whole thing
but watch part if you can't admire joe
biden as a person that's probably you
got a problem
you need to do some self-evaluation
what's not to like
here's what i can tell you
that life can change just like that yeah
don't take it for granted yep don't take
relationships for granted i called him
after bo
died
and he basically said well
bo was my soul
tall for a long time
he came to my ceremony
and said not sure what ceremonies he's
talking about here but i think they say
it in the longer clip but it's some kind
of ceremony received the reward let's
listen to what he says it's some of the
most
incredibly heartfelt things anybody
could ever say to me
and uh
he's the nicest person i think i've ever
been in politics the nicest person he's
ever met in politics
this is this is the per he's talking
about i don't know if anyone knows this
out there but the person that that
lindsey graham is talking about he's
talking about joseph biden who is the
former senator of delaware who is the
former vice president who is currently
the duly elected president of the united
states who hit the president he's
talking about the president that's right
who gets to who gets to nominate who
gets to nominate the nicest person in
politics who gets to nominate supreme
court justices right and then he did
what he did to contend you brown
which you know again just want to point
out the fact that lindsey graham
voted to approve her for her her current
sitting federal uh judge position
right and didn't bring up any of these
questions yeah none of these problems
none of these problems none of these
things were a problem when she was gonna
be and really [__] mcconnell voted for
it too that's right well but people
consider that district court in
washington dc probably the second most
powerful court in the entire country no
problems whatsoever putting her on that
exactly because you also know that
everybody knows that that court
is a is a uh
is a pool
for potential candidates right so they
had to know to some extent that they
were like if we bring her in she might
be
a nominee maybe not
now but she might be later on right and
uh i don't think they ever uh consider
be like oh within a year and a half or
so she would be the nominee
that would uh that be brought in under
under biden so closely they might have
been hoping like oh well you know the
position will wait until
we've got midterms and then we'll have
the control the house and the senate and
they can't do [__] about it right and i
think that's where they're coming from
or at least potentially where they were
thinking but also mitch mcconnell voting
uh yes before and now no
and he even had a tweet yesterday that
said i walked into that committee
hearing with an open mind right like
when they started
i walked in and said yeah i could
consider her for this role
that's complete [__] none of these
guys came in with any sort of
open-mindedness that they had going it
was always going to be a no from the
beginning because they said this woman
person of color not going to offer it to
her so it's just
it's i mean like you know it's like hey
tell me you're racist without telling me
you're racist it's that whole there was
a whole [__] hearing well i mean
we're going to get to the tell me your
race without telling me your race is
here with the next bonehead uh but
mightiest lisa here thank you for the
super chat she's calling out
my skin for being the bonehead of the
chat i'm not sure what's going on over
there in the chat
in the chat but uh
um everyone's
piling on midas ken um
over there in the chat i i love that you
guys are are hashing it out in the chat
of who's the bonehead of the jet this is
fantastic this is fantastic ken it's
nothing against you um sometimes i'm a
bonehead i mean we have a bonehead uh
producer who can't work a microphone
every year yeah i don't know how to i
and well i mean i don't always do that i
always write exactly he doesn't i i
don't always do that i do the transition
sometimes in a boneheaded way let's see
how this transition works to the next
bonehead nominee which is marcia
blackburn which is i used a very vulgar
word no one had no one actually has
attacked me for this which i'm not
that's i'm not surprised
yeah i was potentially concerned yeah
gabe even came into dm and said hey you
might want to reconsider the street i'm
like
who who's going to tell on me who's
going to tell me
i don't know i've seen people obviously
get in trouble for far less on twitter
and you're just you know right well you
know i i really felt that this week
using the word [__] for marsha blackburn
i don't i i even people who are
vehemently against that word
who
it makes them cringe when they hear that
word right
i knew they would be okay
with me using that word
for
um marcia blackburn who was definitely
in the [__] category let's listen
to how [__] she actually is
attempt to pack the supreme court
you have praised the 1619 project which
argues the u.s is a fundamentally racist
country and you have made clear that you
believe judges must consider critical
race theory when deciding how to
sentence criminal defendants is it your
personal hidden agenda to incorporate
critical race theory into our legal
system
these are you trying to start a crt like
that's what they're saying people need
to know well actually in um i know and
i can't say this actual word
but there is a word that that white folk
use for what marsha blackburn is talking
about here it starts with the word in
okay and it and it ends in the in the
sound rise right
um that's what she's talking about here
that's what she's talking about um and
marsha blackburn to say this out loud
and what what's the what the best part
about this is if you watch the video
she's reading word by word like she
almost has a ruler so she can read this
because she obviously
she's read the declaration of
independence at some point in her life
she doesn't know the difference between
the declaration of independence or the
constitution that's one reason why she
is the bonehead of the week but i think
more than anything the reason why this
this bird nest hair [__] is on the
bonehead of the week this week is
because she is a [__] racist it is
clear she's a [__] racist um and and
if she is not she's totally [__]
pretending to be one because if you ask
to ask judge brown jackson which
if you go and you actually look what crt
actually is which the [__] that they're
[__] spewing in school board meetings
that's not crt right that's not crt
that's just called history right yeah
that's just history that's not crt it's
all [__] distraction what they're
talking about with crt here
and judge brown jackson is talking about
is actual the institution being racist
and the practice of making sure that
you're not acting on the systematic
racism inside the justice system when a
[__] justice is making a goddamn
decision about sentencing someone
especially someone who happens to be a
minority who has suffered from the
systematic racism that is in our country
that is institutionally and
systematically racist and if you don't
believe it you're [__] full of [__]
you are full of [__] [__]
now you may not agree with the 69
project you may not agree with them
right but just because you don't agree
with some of the thing policies that
they want to put in place it doesn't
negate the facts that they have before
them
right you know i look at i look at
marsha blackburn you know
and she reminds me
you know she's from tennessee i wouldn't
be surprised if her you know great great
great uh or great great uh
grandfather or grand yeah grandfather uh
was you know fought
as a confederate okay i would be
surprised if her family uh had a
plantation i wouldn't be surprised if
her family had slaves at one point i
wouldn't be surprised if marsha
blackburn had a
familial history
of racist [__] right and she was bred in
that now whether she can hide it or you
know a glass of wine here and things
you know start coming out real easily
but
marsha blackburn
is a is a uh
does a disservice and uh to
the tennessee people and is a is a
disgrace
to
um
a sitting
u.s senator
and
i look at what she did during this
hearing and she used it as an attempt
because also like you can you know if
you if you listen to people's
tone and you listen to a way that they
speak about things right there is even
an exchange uh with uh
with ossoff
where uh she was
he had done a little bit of questioning
and was like
um i'm gonna i'm gonna yield my time to
remainder right and she goes oh well you
know you know i bet he could give you
some tips on being a good like the way
that she said i bet he could give tips
on being a good dad because he's a new
daddy kind of thing was like are you
trying to be condescending because i
think that's what you're trying to do
and it's definitely coming off that way
and then she goes into question these
random things like the day previous she
was talking about what's the definition
of a woman right and then that day she's
talking about well
uh are you just trying to to overtake
the justice system with crt and inject
that in and it's like you mean like an
insurrection on the capitol right
january 6 you know it's like
that's that's the thing here is when
marsha blackburn says that [__] she's
like we do it we do it so you must be
doing it right we are trying to take
over the country and turn it into
something that it's not because we are
doing that so you must be doing that
that's the project the projection is
real right let me show you let me show
you what a real united states senator
um talking to or just anyone with
integrity and compassion and empathy
that's right what you see here is a
human to human interaction
let me show marsha blackburn
what it looks like when a actual
um
person of decency
um actually has joy that this person is
sitting before them being the most
qualified person that's probably ever
set in this committee hearing to be
nominated um this is senator cory booker
and the words that he had to say
to judge brown jackson let's listen you
got here how every black woman in
america has gotten anywhere
has done
by being
like ginger roger said
i did everything fred astaire did but
backwards in heels
and and so i i'm just sitting here
saying nobody's stealing my droid
nobody's gonna make me angry especially
not people that are called in a
conservative magazine
demagogic
for what they're bringing up that just
doesn't hold water i'm not gonna let my
joy be stolen because i know you and i
we appreciate something that we get that
a lot of my colleagues don't i know tim
scott does
when i first came to this place i was
the fourth black person
ever popularly elected to the united
states senate i still remember
a lot of mixed people white folks black
folks work here but at night when people
are in line to come in to clean this
place
the the percentage of minorities shift a
lot and so i'm walking here first week
i'm here and somebody who's been here
for decades doing the
urgent work of the senate but the
unglamorous work that goes on no matter
who's in offices the guy comes up to me
and all he wants to say i can tell is
i'm so happy you're here but he comes up
and he can't get the words out and this
man
my elder starts crying
and i just hugged him and he just kept
telling me it is so good to see you here
so good to see you here
um some words from an actual
sitting united states senator of joy
that this woman was um
welcome into this nomination hearing as
one of the most qualified people to
enter that hearing um and the least
qualified but mind you the least
qualified is uh amy coney barrett
right has not tried a case right and was
was given a real oly
kind of approach to
uh questions you know you look at josh
hawley and ted cruz and lindsey graham
and they're all like oh yeah you look
very you're you're you're very uh
uh well informed and intelligent and
considerate and you are one of
uh
of great you know
great right
great legal mind right cause you are
white
yeah i mean well it's speaking of josh
alley uh you actually made josh hawley
the alpha cuck of the week yeah um
alpha cuck as everyone knows what an
alpha cuck is it's it's the guy in the
room who has to um
who has to say they're the alpha which
makes you not
the alpha the alpha yeah um so josh
holly is the the alpha cuck of the week
um now josh holley did a lot of alpha
cuck style things this week um but what
specifically made you pick out josh
hawley for the alpha kick uh
i mean
the commodities
right yeah so i look at you know there
one is there's comparison footage of how
we handle this committee hearing and how
he handled amy coney barrett's committee
meeting it was very much kind of what i
just mentioned which was like him being
like oh yeah you're so great and you're
a person of faith right not like very
easy questions very
um
congratulatory or uh
uh ones that were like
um giving you knows compliments really
and then you you've got um
the committee hearing that just happened
this week
and it's the complete opposite right
like he's he's concerned about [__]
child porn and pedophiles and has this
weird obsession
with
porn like child porn and we talked about
it's like every time i would write that
[__] out on on a tweet because you
message me and you're like god i hate
[__] tweeting child porn
but these [__] weirdos and it's like
right
it's it's insanity that this week
the republican party decided that the
discussion that the discussion that the
country should have
is how they are obsessed with child porn
and the reason why it became that
narrative is because they really [__]
this up um let me see if i can find the
clip because ted cruz really tried to
run
uh
you know clean up on this because what
happened was in this hearing when they
started to bring up how katanji brown
jackson judge brown jackson had made
decisions on sentencing for uh
pedophiles or
sex predators or child sex predators or
for people who had been convicted of
child porn
they dug deep into the voting record of
josh hawley ted cruz all these
republicans voting for judges who had
made the exact same sentencing and they
had voted for them or even
right right not even questioned them so
it really made them not just look like
complete [__] [__] but look like
they are completely obsessed with child
porn when it comes to a black woman when
it comes to child porn not only that
it's obvious what they're trying to do
here they're trying to appeal to the ch
jenny thomases of the world the q and
honors of the world
um to bring up this child sex trouble
it's the great it's the cabal like
that's right
but here here is a clip and i believe
this clip has judge brown jackson josh
hawley and
also another contestant on this week's
bonus of the week ted cruz so let's
watch this clip
mr chairman senator ronald's time mr
chairman i'm asking you to be recognized
to make a point to the chair this is
this is uh let me give some context
because it on the clip here
um it missed part of the um the entry
here the context is is that taker's
pipes in here this is after josh hawley
has finishing question uh questioning
judge brown jackson about the child porn
which is so [__] gross that i don't
even really want to show that [__] um
because he's absolutely obsessed with it
but this is where this is where ted cruz
jumps in on um a letter and the reason
why he wants to jump in is because he's
trying to run cleanup on josh hawley
because of how judge brown jackson
describes how judge federal judges are
and have guidelines that they're adhered
to now they can go down on those
guidelines but they can't go over on
those guidelines like there is a federal
a maximum sentence that they can give to
people especially when these
pre-sentencing
um
the pre-sentencing report is given to
the prosecutor is given to the judge and
these things are under seal these are
not things that the public sees and what
josh holly and ted cruz want to do is
want to give
an endanger and you'll see dick durbin
clean it up here but they're trying to
run clean up on their obsession with
child porn here by dragging uh
kbj through this mess of how they want
to expose
these victims of these crimes that she
had to make sure she sentenced correctly
mm-hmm
mr chairman senator ronald's time
recognizing mr chairman to the chairman
it's [__] idiot i believe he
recognized
you hear senator patrick leahy um
chime in here like get this [__] [__]
this guy [__] this guy's what he wanted
that's what i would say that's why i
can't be in the united states because i
[__] this guy you know you know that do
you know that he's been in five batman
films who's that leahy yeah he's a big
batman fan
he's been in five of them yeah really i
didn't know that we'll have to talk
about that maybe we'll do a video or
something let's see
mr chairman the witness just said that
we cannot understand those cases without
the free sentence i don't want to go
through this again i have a letter that
i want to enter into the record and you
notice that dick durbin has to say go
through this again like we've said this
over and over we are not going to let
you run clean up that you guys are
obsessed with child porn because kbj in
in in a in a video earlier in the week
she completely destroys them on how
the pre-sentencing guidelines in the
pre-sentencing report is given to the
judge how the prosecutor suggests their
recommendation the judge has to take the
law the prosecutor and the guidelines
and also the pre-sentencing report in
mind when they're doing their sentencing
like there's a whole process that she
goes through to explain to these [__]
idiots how it works which they know josh
holly ted cruz mike lee
cornyn all these [__] scumbags
lindsey graham they know how this now
marcia blackburn probably doesn't but
they all [__] know signed by ten
senators on this committee
do you are you not even going to allow
the letter from town
on this committee any letter you can do
it
this letter that is signed by ten
senators on the committee okay signed
yeah like can you be like like if i was
dick durbin could i hold someone in
contempt like could i get them like well
i mean you know there are procedures but
it's i mean it's it's kind of the same
thing of you know like how valid is it
right like it it only it only is going
to be effective if the senator here the
[__] scumbag ted cruz um
adheres to what the rule is that dick
durbin you know puts together yeah
because i want to know like could i put
this little baby that's having a tantrum
in a time out you know right could could
you do that or is it one of those like
you got to listen
to this [__]
[__] ass ted cruz go like
i mean they can't send he can cut his
mic i mean they can cut his mic i mean
i'm sure that dick durbin can say your
time you don't have time right i mean i
do i do wish you got your mic in some
ways
you know kind of like doing a debate
that you're in somewhat of this isil you
know not a chamber but you're in an
isolated kind of you know box
and if your mic's on you talk we hear
you but we could kill your mic and then
it just sounds like you're muted you
know kind of like how i come into the
show without the mic going right exactly
well you know
it's it's tough to you know i i just
figured i could relate so you're
comparing yourself to ted cruz now this
is this well i'm not comparing myself to
you i'm just comparing the situation
okay okay i got you all right let's
continue these cases without reading the
probation reports
ten senators on this committee are
asking the chairman mr chairman to
provide those reports so we can do what
judge jackson just chaired right which
is to assess those reports and here it
is junior
most of us have been here a long time
trying to follow the rules
he very easily hands you a letter in the
record
he's saying he's doing this to help
senator hawley senator hawley could have
put it in he didn't yeah that's right
because cinderella is a [__] bonehead
and that's why that's why him and ted
cruz ended up on the list this week um
which if you don't know we we know who
the winner is at this point but but
before we go to the winner before we go
to the winner
i want to give you the uh dishonorable
mention of the week uh jenny thomas
now obviously
we know at this point because i've
ranted all the whole [__] show
about this
bonehead um
who is jenny thomas but gabe um do we do
we have some of the we we
are able to read some of these
these messages correct yeah yeah yeah
i mean this is this is the thing that we
can actually do we can actually go see
these in the washington post article but
if if we were so inclined i think
there's actually video
of um you know like a germanic reading
maybe these videos let's see if we can
oh here we go let's see if we can find
it's uh mr it's uh mr fort and perjury
yeah
is that who this is
it's the same hair yeah it's almost
identical you don't exactly speak it's
like almost like newt gingrich you know
really
is it is it new does newt smoke about
i'll tell you i'm gonna i'm gonna have a
uh
um i'm gonna destroy the very end of
this for everyone here who hasn't seen
this but at the very end you have to
watch
the pipe the lipping of the pipe pay
attention to the dismount with the
lipping of the pipe let's let's listen
to the dramatic reading of the seditious
sexting
from jenny thomas to mark meadows hello
and welcome to a dramatic reading of
text messages sent to mark meadows from
jenny thomas help this great president
stand firm mark you are the leader
with him who is standing for america's
constitutional governance at the
precipice
the majority knows biden in the left is
attempting the greatest heist
of our history sounds like sydney and
her team are getting inundated with
evidence of fraud inundated make a plan
release the kraken and save us from the
left taking america down i can't see
america swallowing
anointed
the lipping the lipping of the pipe uh
at the very end so let's go back to some
of these uh these messages here's
because i i just want these are [__]
real by the way these are these are real
text messages i did not edit any of
these this is exactly how they are typed
out
in in the report of the watching in the
report this is how you know all ellipses
and exclamation points and
capitalizations
all are identical verbatim to what she
said i did not modify it right you
didn't change any of it there's even one
i couldn't even put in here because it
was much longer than i wanted it to be
right so there's like another text that
was available and keep in mind these are
only three
four texts of a total of 21 that she
sent also that we know of that right
but keep in mind
the the ratio she sent 21 and mark
meadows set back eight
like someone is a little obsessed and a
little desperate and mark man was like
god damn it i'm [__] dealing with it
i'm trying to work on this but think
about this is this is this why they got
so many [__] people and and to beli
that you would think there's no way
these people would believe this is that
the [__] wife of a supreme court
justice believed this garbage
believed this stuff
because really really it's not it's not
like
that it wasn't obvious of the evidence
that was there right or or that wasn't
there more more like but this this um
here where she says
the heist of our history
like what the [__] are you talking about
the
heist the the style of writing
is reminiscent in terms of like which
words are capitalized is reminiscent of
trump i'm just putting that out there
huh well do you think maybe trump was
trying to like i don't know go wait go
back to the second second message oh
yeah right there right okay release the
kraken right what
what has been uh
okay well wait a second wait a second
wait a second here because because the
first thing here is she said
sounds like sydney and her team are
getting inundated
like what
just because people are piling up
[__] stories about how there's fraud
which is the case that they're i saw a
bunch of people throwing them the
ballots out right well but here's the
thing is i talked about earlier how
sidney powell you know i'm trying to
connect all the dots here sidney powell
stood on stage with rudy giuliani when
his [__] [__] for brains was leaking
out of his skull you remember this and
she was saying crazy [__] like uh
about the voting machines so much crazy
[__] in fact even the guy who had his
[__] for brains running down his face
was like well maybe we shouldn't have
her
talk anymore in official capacity and
you remember the story there trump was
like oh she's not my lawyer i don't even
know who the [__] sidney powell is and
it's like oh was she not in the oval
office with mike flynn and you
discussing how to over turn the election
right but here here you see
a wife
of an elite of the supreme court justice
texting this to the chief of staff this
isn't like they were texting like the
the the [__] cook the second the
second shift cook in the kitchen of the
white house yeah it wasn't like they
were sending each other like oh what'd
you get on wordle today i was like why
don't we overturn the election right and
and and then she says the kraken thing
because the craziest part to me
is that she is telling the chief of
staff that sydney powell
has
all
the evidence
you just put up minus robin said daniel
dale will back you
yeah uh we would welcome daniel to come
on the show and fact check this video um
but yeah she did she she did say release
the kraken
which is [__] crazy i i you know i
gotta
in my mind composing the tweet but i
gotta figure out like
has there been
a bigger flop
than the kraken
like
how many here's the thing like
videos on tick tock videos on on clapper
you know the wannabe tick tock uh in
other places people were [__]
pounding down the doors to be like the
kraken is coming we're gonna release the
kraken oh man just wait this was
this was pre let's go brandon right
right this is pretty let's go brandon
this is the let's go brandon before
let's go right because at that meeting
she goes we're gonna release the kraken
and everyone's like oh [__] [__]
kraken this mythical beast this thing is
gonna be a massive dump of [__] oh
it was a joke oh it was a jump
it was a jump
massive dump of
uh a
voter fraud and all these cases and all
this proof that the election was in fact
stolen and it should have gone to donald
trump and then you find out that they
keep saying it it's gonna happen here
it's like michael and dell pushing back
when the supreme court is gonna make a
nine zero
uh uh uh a decision well on september
89th that's when they're gonna
that's when donald trump will ascend to
the white house right exactly
king of the united states you have
this kraken again this mythical this
mythical beast right that's talked about
and [__]
[__] you know pirate stories and
other stuff you think do you think the
cracking the actual kraken's like
sitting in its apartment eating cheetos
watching all this like these people just
keep talking about me yeah and this is
crazy i'm famous now like i don't i
don't know if i don't know if he was
like i'm famous or if he was eating you
know he was having a beer or something
on the couch and he goes
what the [__]
and he's like
i don't have anything to do with this
election god damn it stop dragging my
name through this [__] do you think do
you think the kraken and don junior's
cocaine bag of cocaine are friends i'm
just saying maybe i think they can
relate
right yeah you know they could
definitely be friends and hang out
probably but yeah i totally see the
kraken on the couch he's watching the
news she says his name or its name and
then all of a sudden he spits out the
beer and he's like
what you know and then from there he's
you know he's like right he's getting
knocks on the door from the fbi and all
kinds of [__]
i don't know i have no idea
i don't know anything i don't even know
who sydney powell is
i never knew who she was before this
moment right right uh but yeah uh the
biggest flop of all time
the kraken right now like just
on the deck just flat out flaccid
well here's here's another uh
uh just a gem in these uh tweets i can't
see americans swallowing the obvious
fraud
um which in in in my in my universe of
seditious sex messaging the swallowing
of the obvious fraud is perfect in that
universe um but then she goes on to say
uh no freaking consequences i think
that's that is
every time i read
freaking consequences i think of like
some little kids like oh god doing them
or like you know who i think of napoleon
dynamite where he's like
freaking
freaking yep
hey hey tina come eat your freaking ham
you know like that's what i imagine is
being said because what adult if you're
gonna say all this other dumb [__]
freaking is the is the worst word you're
gonna say in this right you're like i
can't swear i can't say [__] right
right right well and then and then she
goes on then then she goes on to say
whole coup like she points out like the
projection here
and then says biden to be
anointed like you mean elected like what
do you mean
is he being knighted like right i don't
think he's getting a crown like actually
he beat bernie sanders in the primary
right and then he beat trump in the
general like he wasn't like it wasn't
like bernie sanders won and then
everyone's like you know we're not gonna
do that we're just gonna make biden the
president
they are projecting like full on can't
even [__] understand the q and on
[__] that they're projecting here like
you want to anoint donald trump to be
king of the united states and you're
projecting it on to joe biden which is
absolutely bonkers yeah but again um one
more time what is what is the gop
charade i want to know that is that
supposed to be like the rhinos well i
mean they are a charade for sure if
that's what you're asking
yeah
one more time with the dismount i love
the dismount here oh
text messages sent to mark meadows from
jenny thomas
the lipping the lipping of the the pipe
yeah this month
let me tell you i had i did multiple
takes because i was like i gotta make
sure i'm in in frame and i gotta
you know just
go for the you know i don't want to
throw it in my mouth i gotta very ever
ever so lightly yeah it was it was a
great dismount it's a great dismantle so
let's go to the winner this week and we
don't have a lot of time left and really
i don't think we have enough we don't
really need a lot of time right between
marshall blackburn ted cruz and lindsey
graham our winner this week is ted cruz
of course um i actually i was surprised
last week when he lost by so much right
he he didn't i don't think he broke five
percent last week
yeah it was like four to six percent
something like that he in the last hour
in the last hour
overtook marshall blackburn i even tried
to tweet it out a couple times this
morning to see if we could get her to be
the bonnet right but everyone
everyone hates taking when i went to
when i went to bed
last night aka this morning which was
like probably 3 00 a.m
uh
it was
36.6
for both of them it technically had
marsha blackburn in the winning so i i
had set up all the assets to be marcia
blackburn
one i just assumed she was gonna win i
thought oh yeah well you know what
she's got this one it's close but i
think it'll close out i don't see many
votes coming back in right and then
it ends up being like 36 to 38
for ted cruz and i was like what he
pulled that one uh last minute right
last minute well let's let's go to al
franken because al franken has the the
reason why ted cruz pulled it out let's
listen what about ted cruz ted cruz
makes up a big part of your what makes
up a chunk uh well what i what i say is
that i probably liked
ted cruz more than most of my colleagues
like ted cruz and i hate ted cruz
and if anyone wants to know alfred can
actually sell sells that phrase on a
[__] coffee mug he put that in a book
he's like i like i like takers
more than most of my colleagues and i
hate i hate
i know on that on that interview he he
really wanted to say and i [__] hate
ted right yeah he definitely wanted to
say [__] he couldn't of course
because he was on uh cnn but right but i
wish he could so let's give let's give
ted cruz his due because he came in at
the very last hour and beat out marsha
blackburn let's let's give ted cruz's
[Applause]
[Music]
uh so ted cruz he he wins you know
if anyone doesn't know gabe really pays
close attention to the details on the
horse race there on the graphics so if
you guys are just listening out there to
the bone of the week you have to come
over to youtube and check out um watch
the bone of the week because gabe works
very hard on that being very very
accurate yeah a depiction of the vote
yeah um he's he's he's very meticulous
hey listen i don't i don't call it in
for this stuff okay i don't half-ass
this right i mean
he can't figure out the mic but he
definitely pays attention to the details
yes
the devil is in the details right and
and congratulations again to ted cruz
for being the bonehead of the week um no
better person to be the bonehead of the
week than than ted cruz i think i think
you know
yeah no he's uh i mean like again you
know i wish uh you know i would i and
tony both agree that yes we could say
all of the above for these uh
these right these races however
we need to accept only one winner okay
we can't have we can't have ties we
can't have uh
uh all of the above we need a one clear
winner so each week we can say
that was the [__] bonehead
so go to at tony michael's pod follow us
there for the bonehead of the week poll
and come watch every friday in the
second hour us break down the bonehead
of the week break down your vote for the
bonehead of the week this has been the
bonehead of the this week and and make
sure to and make sure to look out for
bonehead madness not being used with
march madness that's right
right bonehead madness uh check that out
uh make sure you're watching and
following twitter this has been bone of
the week stay with us we have some
announcements announcements right after
the sun
[Music]
[Applause]
all right bonehead of the week i think
it was a good bone hint of the weak pole
yeah i think it turned out
solid solid contenders solid contenders
again don't forget to go follow at tony
michael's pod for the bonehead of the
week pull and where are you going to be
putting this um this bonehead madness
that are we going to be putting it on
the the podcast and then we'll tweet it
out and and yeah yeah yeah i think so
yeah we'll i'll tweet it out so today
and uh to veteran yoda yes the former
guy he's not in uh
uh the running i can give you the list
right i'll just read off the names right
yeah let's read the list for the
senators i have ted cruz josh hawley
lindsey graham and i had rand paul
however i did a quick audible and put in
marcia blackburn because she really came
out this week and in right and she
showed her bonehead yeah she yeah she
she tried to prove herself then for u.s
representatives i've got margaret taylor
green madison cawthorne lauren bobert
and matt gates of course
always always reliable boneheads right
always then we've got a lame stream
media section which is tucker carlson
charlie kirk
sean hannity and candace owens okay
great that's right so we've got senators
representatives lane street media and
then we've got this other group right
now which is ron desantis
greg abbott
mike flynn
and donald trump jr okay so so a couple
governors so we can't call it governors
right i thought about that but then i
was like maybe it's maybe it's coke kids
i don't i don't know i don't know i
don't know i mean do they all do coke i
don't know oh i mean you could make a
strong argument for them so today
today we will have four pulls that will
go out it'll be for uh you know i got to
determine what the bracket is or
sorry eight eight pulls
so i'll do four today and four tomorrow
okay and then on sunday uh we'll do
uh
two
or four and then on monday we'll do four
and then we'll we'll break it down to
the final are we going to announce the
bonehead madness winner next week on
bonehead
uh we could okay let's let's do that
we'll announce the winner of course
you'll know by then but we will announce
the winner of
bonehead madness next week on bone in
the week so don't forget next week
uh watch friday in the second hour
again every single weekday noon eastern
11 central but on friday in the second
hour we will do bone in the week we will
announce the winner of bonehead madness
don't forget to follow us and subscribe
and like and all that kind of stuff
you're supposed to do until monday at
noon eastern 11 central it's been it's
been great week and i'm sure it's going
to be a news field weekend
don't miss monday's show noon eastern 11
central nine pacific right here on
youtube twitter twitch and also now on
the midas touch facebook page thanks for
joining us have a great weekend surf's
up [__]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking